[Music]
humans dependence on fossil fuels is
heating up the planet with an
unprecedented rate governments and
policymakers must take urgent action
that action is guided by what science
says by the impact of climate change on
the earth this is how it's calculated
[Music]
this is ver Hamby Agnes at the end of
the 19th century he devised formulas
which linked the flow of heat water and
air 50 years later his ideas were the
basis of the first computer model the
atmosphere a modern day weather
forecasting is born today's climate
models are the highly evolved
descendants of that original except the
computers as some twenty-five trillion
times faster here's how it works
scientists divide the Earth's atmosphere
into a grid of hundreds of thousands of
cells and stacks like a skyscraper the
model used by the Met Office Britain's
National Weather Service for example
uses stacks which are 85 cells high the
models then calculate how energy air and
water vapor flow through each cell over
a given time period well weather
forecasting takes a snapshot of the
atmosphere at a given time
and predicts what will happen over the
next few days climate models consider
the atmospheres behavior over years and
years simulating either the world as it
is
or the world as it might be they sketch
out the sort of processes and the sort
of results that you might see and that
allows you to inform policy to some
extent one of the classic things that
climate models have always done is just
look at the world if the carbon dioxide
level were twice as high as it is today
that was one of the first ways that
climate models began to illustrate the
fact that greenhouse warming really was
likely to be a problem in the 21st
century for all their complexity these
models have limitations although you're
cutting the atmosphere into millions of
cells the atmosphere it's a very big
thing and a millionth of a big thing is
still a pretty big thing so the cells
tend to be there maybe hundreds of
kilometers on a side
this means the models often struggle to
capture details like cloud cover and
clouds play a key role in climate as
greenhouse gases made the atmosphere
warmer it changed the amount of water
vapor it can hold and how air rises and
falls that in turn changes the amount
and character of cloud cover
depending on where clouds form they can
either trap sunlight which warms the
planet will reflect it back into space
cooling it and some processes which
govern cloud formation work on a very
small scale so you can't actually model
those precise processes in the computer
models they have to build various
different rules of thumb mean for what
would you expect the clouds to be doing
how you do that means that your model
will behave differently compared to
someone else's model where they do that
in a different way
dozens of these models exist run by
teams all over the world the modelers
all want to capture the earth as close
as possible to how it is but there are
assumptions about how that actually
works differ from model to model and the
ways that they implement those
assumptions change
some models tend to people say run hot
so they tend to provide more warming for
a given amount of carbon dioxide and
some models tend to run a little cold
every few years the models are brought
together fed standardized questions and
then their results are compared this
helps scientists understand the
strengths and weaknesses of different
climate models and improves them of
course it's impossible to assess the
model's future projections but what
researchers can do is compare the
success of models from previous decades
a recent report compared the models from
the 1970s to the 2000s and it found that
by and large they were reasonably good
that the warming that would actually
seen sat within the error bars for most
of them so it gave us a like general
sense that these things weren't
completely out of the park the climate
models are getting increasingly
complicated capturing more aspects of
the earth but there is one element that
is impossible to model and it is the
biggest contributor to climate change
[Music]
the thing about human activity is that
you can't get it inside the model the
model deals with sort of like physical
laws of chemistry and physics and
biology so that there's no way the model
can say well in 2050 America will have
stopped emitting carbon dioxide instead
scientists take simplified results from
these climate models and run them
through economic models in 2013
scientists use these models to examine
the effect of different climate policies
on the future temperature of the planet
the first looked at what would happen if
there was continued large-scale use of
coal the second if there was continued
use of fossil fuels but some use of
renewable energy the third if there was
a much higher uptake of renewable energy
and the fourth if there was a lot of use
of carbon capture technology more land
to grow biofuels
the striking thing about those
comparisons and by other combatants will
come out later is the only really tough
climate policies get you the sort of
trajectories which keep the temperature
in the words of the Paris agreement well
under two degrees above the
pre-industrial what these models tell us
is that the current level of emissions
reduction is not remotely enough to have
any assurance that you will stay under
two degrees left even less all right
close to 1.5 degrees
climate models don't predict the future
and they're not perfect there is a long
way to go before they fully represent
all of Earth's intricate processes but
for now they are the only way the
scientists have understanding how
damaging an increase in carbon dioxide
will be for the planet ultimately the
solution to climate change won't lie
inside models but rather what humans
choose to do with the information they
provide I'm Oliver Morton
I'm the briefings editor at The
Economist we've written a series of
climate briefs to cover the basics and a
bit more than the basics on all sorts of
aspects of the climate crisis that's
facing the earth you can read them all
at the link opposite thank you for
watching
you